(rap music)
- The number one job dream
of every 13 to 16-year-old in
America is to be a
YouTuber and/or an influencer.
(rap music)
("One Dance" by MadReal)
- [DRock] We're here.
- So about to do a FaceTime now.
A lot of you do the 60 Second
Club and know about the little
gifts and things that nature.
(bell dings) 60 Second Club is
when you post a comment and a
hashtag or just a
hashtag on my Instagram post.
A lot of people
turn on my notifications
on Instagram for that.
It's just a fun little thing.
Lot of people are like, "Oh,
you're not hustling 'cause
"you're a part
of 60 Second Club."
And I love when
they do that actually.
I love when you
guys do that but,
you got to mix fun into stuff
and it's just like a fun little
game that we're doing.
I'm actually gonna do a
little more fun on Instagram.
Gonna do some more
giveaway, more cheesy fun.
I mean it.
Giveaways, contests, like first
one to notice what color's in
the background or
how many of these.
You know what I mean?
I want to do a
little more of that fun.
Anyway, good to
be doing more fun.
Phone call.
Damn it, I was
doing a good rant.
Jon, what's up?
I'm in the middle of a good rant
so you know you're important for
me to pick this up.
("One Dance" by MadReal)
I got it. I got it, okay.
Thanks, bye-bye.
So where was I?
And obviously put music all
over that 'cause that's another
fucking fire in my life.
What was I saying? Fun.
- [DRock] Giveaways.
- Giveaways.
- [DRock] You had
just gotten to--
- What was I
about to talk about.
- [DRock] Doing FaceTimes.
- Oh yeah, so one of
the cool things is access.
Better than t-shirt, better than
a book is access and what
I'm doing right now
is I'm giving access.
What we're doing right now
is doing a FaceTime
on Snapchat.
So I think one of the great
things to do is to absolutely
be part of 60 Second
Club to win access
'cause it's fucking impossible.
I look like a Christmas tree.
Hey Ari, how are you?
With a YouTube channel you can
go super niche and be all about
jelly beans or you can
be day in the life vlog,
I think at the end
of the day both work.
I think you just
need to know yourself.
If you have something that
you're super hard core expertise
in, that you have super hard
core expertise in or a super
hard core passion well then
that's something that you want
to talk about for the next five,
ten years then I'm comfortable
with niche but I think people
are always trying to find which
one's better and
the truth is, Ari,
that it's better
based on the person.
There's no general answer.
It's more
predicated on you, right?
What feels right to you?
How long have you been doing it?
Good, you know
what I'm gonna say.
Four months is just not enough
time to decide if this is right
or not right.
Keep trying different things.
And really if you
want to win as a vlogger,
you know, it's funny.
Every 15-year-old and now every
30-year-old in the world wants
to be an influencer or a YouTube
celebrity, right?
And the reality is is if that's true...
The reason
everybody wants to do that is
'cause it's an
awesome life, right?
And so, if that's true,
that's what one wants I don't
understand how people are not
committed to doing it every day
for 18 to 24 months before
they begin to even doubt should
should I jump off this.
The thought of jumping off early
on something that
is so amazing, right?
I think it's more about you
interacting with them when you
have a small following.
So you should message and direct
message every single person.
Every single person watching my
vlog right now if they have 300
or less people following them on
Instagram tonight they should DM
every single person and say
thank you for following me.
What are you following me for?
And is there
anything I can do for you.
That's the quickest
way to go from 300 to 800.
Putting out content is the cost
of entry for major upside
in the game in my opinion.
And then you just got
to hope it's interesting,
entertaining,
makes people escape,
educates them, motivates them.
You know, I think the reason
I work is I educate people,
I think I definitely
motivate people and
I think I entertain people.
I think that's, when you think
about the three pillars that if
you've actually got, I'm
sure I probably over-index in
motivation and maybe a
little less in entertainment and
really, really
great in education,
and so, you know but there's a
lot of people that don't do any
of those three things.
And that's why
nobody fucking watches them.
(laughs) Alright.
You're welcome.
(blows kisses)
Alright, that was good.
That whole thing.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- From the Jon call,
the whole thing.
That's it, we're in a
good place now for the episode.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- It doesn't take much.
- [DRock] Do you think that--
- Actually as a matter of fact,
actually I have a pretty
important thing that you should
share this with the whole team.
I think we should actually go
through a period of time of
making the vlog vlog-ier.
You know, now I feel ready so
for example that was interesting
because I got interrupted.
This and that.
I feel like we can
base the whole thing on...
Anything that I'm doing for one
to four minutes that is unusual,
I think should now
take more precedence.
- [DRock] Because
we're doing so much of the
meeting talk already.
- Correct.
And just we've
done it for a while.
And so for me, an entire episode
around the green room dynamics
or me playing bubble hockey with
Justin and then Tyler, you or
Iris or Justin asking me about
being competitive and the whole
thing's about why
I wanted to crush Justin,
and I did successfully crush
Justin's face in bubble hockey.
Yeah, so I think we all start
challenging ourselves with that.
And that's that.
("One Dance" by MadReal)
It's all of it.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Gary] It's the whole thing.
It's all a mental game.
It's not much of it.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- It's the operating
system of everything you do.
I just traded for Kris Bryant
from Staats which completes over
the last six hours me
fire sale-ing my entire team in
fantasy baseball and
setting myself up for next year.
It just didn't work out.
- Hey everybody,
how you guys doing?
This is a special,
special edition of
The Danny Morrell Show.
("One Dance" by MadReal)
- I was so focused in my 20s
to build the empire that I
imagined, it just wasn't my
driving force as the cliche
would play out for most guys
at that time in their lives.
And I bring it up because
I am concerned that the current
conversation on social media,
Instagram specifically, around
entrepreneurship--
- [Danny] Yeah, yeah.
- is so skewed to
champagne bottles,
models, private jets,
Lambos, rare animals,
all sorts of weird shit.
- [Danny] Right.
- And nobody's talking about
the truth which is why I did
DailyVee which is the
truth is not fucking glamorous.
- [Danny] Right.
- I realize that I'm being
treated very differently right
now by 15 to 25-year-old guys
and if I can inspire young men
to be better human beings in the
way that men run through this
world, that could be
a really cool legacy.
- Absolutely.
("Flume" by MadReal)
- [Gary] This is
not some fad, you know,
that's gonna be
around for a little bit.
This is the fundamental shift
of how human being interact with
each other which is the
currency of our lives.
I don't think this room
including myself actually
understands how big of an
opportunity this is
in whatever you care about.
Your entire life,
regardless of industry,
over the next decade will
be eaten up by technology.
And either you're
on the eating side
or you're on the other side.
And so, we have a
a little window here.
I've been doing my
thing for 20 years.
Not forever but
long enough to know this,
I've only seen it twice.
This is like
getting electricity.
This is big shit.
And this is big shit not only
in your business life but in the
dynamics of who you are.
(audience cheers and
applause)
Thank you, man.
Thank you my man.
Thank you. Take care.
("Flume" by MadReal)
- You feeling like.
- Yep.
- It's hard work and
there's a missing puzzle piece.
You can plug that in and boom.
- I think the one that's really
working for me right now is
you're gonna die.
- [Man] Yes! (laughs) Positive.
- It's actually very positive.
It's been interesting to
see how people've reacted
to when I said that.
It's just how I think which is
like why do you not maximize
instead of worrying
about how all these things are,
why don't you enjoy the fact
that you actually have a life
and go do something
about it so my big one is,
you're gonna die so
do something about it.
- Boom! Do something!
Thank you, Gary.
- Great to see you.
Heading to the airport now.
Red eye.
Promised myself
I wouldn't do any red eyes.
Like five already this year.
It's ridiculous.
Went like three years,
two years without one.
- [DRock] Really?
- Yeah.
- [DRock] I didn't know that.
- Uh-huh.
("One Dance" by MadReal)